this isn't the normal pickup no Sean it
was it was quite an experience and quite
frankly sir I will do it anytime Vernon
Warner's first Fair of the day here on
Prosperity pathway in Scarborough a
pregnant woman asking to go downtown to
a birthing center but as he drove West
on the highway the taxi driver decided
to deviate the plan after he heard this
she need help she said driver helped me
he got off on Markham Road pulled into a
parking lot at this McDonald's to call
for help I was advised then to carry on
and try to make it to the nearest
hospital but the woman wasn't going to
make it that far the baby's on the way
Vernon drove into this gas station while
getting instructions from a 9-1-1
operator as the woman in labor spoke on
the phone with a midwife who talked her
through hold on to the neck and pull
down to the mom
I looked around like this and the baby
was in her hand everything went right
today because he was the person who was
meant to be there for her baby
deliveries and taxis are rare in this
case Vernon's decision to get off the
highway and find a safe place to stop
for the delivery was key Vernon knew
exactly what to do and he engaged he
paid attention and he was empathetic and
understanding and wanting to take care
of her paramedics arrived about five
minutes later and the mother was
transported to Centenary hospital she
and her baby's son are fine the lady was
quite grateful she was she was really
happy that
it turned out to be me as her driver
and
I think I was the right person for the
job Sean Shea Global News
[Music]